Let's look at another example of cognitive dissonance and see how to help
decrease the discomfort caused by cognitive dissonance. Let's say we have a
person who is cheating on her lover. Can you think of examples that fit into
each of the three categories that we discussed that might help decrease that
discomfort caused by the dissonance? First, how might the person change her
behavior. Well one thing she could do is end the affair. Second, she could try
to justify her behavior. For example, perhaps she says that she's not hurting
anybody by having the affair. Third she may try to change her ideas or her
thoughts in order to justify her behavior. For example, maybe she says, I'm
pretty sure he cheated on me, or if he can cheat, I can cheat. Now, before I
move on to the next area of social relations, I'd like you to think about any
personal experiences that you have had that have resulted in cognitive
dissonance. What did you do to try to decrease the uncomfortable feelings that
you experienced?